I'm up almost 10 pounds since I started
dealing with this guy two and a half
months ago and he's just so many
measurements what's that butt leaner no
leaner no no no I'm still at like 13 and
a half pounds of uh or sorry uh 13.5
body fat so my body fat obviously you
know went up a little bit because it's a
percentage of the weight that you gain
yeah um but we're not we're not focusing
on cutting we're just focusing on
improving weak areas which um are coming
along great so we took some measurements
and I posted them up on my stories and
uh on on Twitter
um as they say you can't manage what
you're not measuring so that's what that
was all about
yeah I've got a cut we're going to Miami
in a couple weeks in the top it's not an
official sanctioned Meetup but it ended
up being that enough guys were going for
the top 10 group the admins are like oh
you know we'll go ahead and go to but uh
there's certain cities that I go to
Miami Los Angeles Las Vegas where you I
just have to have a six-pack there's no
there's no exception and uh I always
tell guys guys if you've never if you
think you can't get a six-pack you can
if you think you can't get buff you can
and if you haven't done it before try it
at least one time in your life like go
okay go go all out do the effort try
getting a six-pack go to Music Festival
go to a beach type party thing and just
see see what happens it's a good
experience to have I think okay I'm
gonna start topping you for that my 15
year old son is on my case he goes to
the gym regularly it's one of the things
I totally encourage him to do I don't
have to encourage him he wants to uh
it's the only place I'll drop I'll drive
him at the drop of a hat but he's like I
want to get a six-pack I'm doing this
I'm doing that so I'm gonna DM you after
the show and get some advice
he's like putting away the bag of
Cheetos and he's like why don't we talk
about it live since we're on the air and
it seems to be a topic of interest and
we're honored okay so Jaren what's yeah
what are your best tips on it
used to be fat right like can I yeah I
was like 38 body fat or something crazy
like you have a do you have a before and
after picture on your Instagram still
yeah I do I do somewhere um I don't have
one at Peak fatness but I can send you
one real quick
my sister my sister does the
scrapbooking things it's just a slug of
fat photos I got one yeah don't forget
where you came from like cool thanks for
sure forget where you came from yeah
how do I add the string add a stream
that's it right there we go so that's so
that's you that's like not even at your
fattest is what you're saying that
wasn't fattest no that was that was in
my 20s I was doing the vegan thing
living in California so just really no
muscle mass kind of a skinny fat look
yeah that picture that picture on the
left actually looks buff compared to the
other pictures of you I've seen
yeah I've got some I've got some real
fat ones let me
it's a new Google driveway because I did
a video on it one time I saw I saw one
of you where you're just like basically
um like blobbed out like you look like
Jabba the Hutt
it looks like the guy from the Subway
commercial and the other Darren
but I want to went to prison oh yeah the
the pedo yes what did that guy go to
prison for yeah
oh okay yeah
oh okay hang on hang on I found another
one here on your feet
um okay cool yeah I've got some I've got
some real flowers because my Peaks are
big there yeah that's what I was going
through my divorce so I was like 2 35
there I think but my Peak fatness is
like 285 and I lost all that weight when
I was 16 17 years old yeah
so best steps to cut
activity now so for me lower carbs
usually works pretty well doing the
intermittent fasting I did one meal a
day I will kick start my workouts with
like 50 grams of protein maybe some
carbohydrates if I need them but I have
a type of body where I don't really need
carbohydrates I'll fall into the myth
like okay well I need the carbohydrates
because I'm not getting as much out of
my workouts but I just get big I just
put on a lot of mass if I'm doing the
higher carbs so normally I'll run the
cons on the lower side I don't do a pure
ketogenic type type diet I'll keep it
like 50 to 100 carbs
um it's been rich like you said measure
everything so for the very first time I
decided like hey I'm going to get a
six-pack I don't care what it takes I
built a fat loss tracker I've shared
with guys in the groups and then I did a
dexa scan took on my measurements
plugged in where I was at plugged in on
my target goals about halfway through
that first time getting the six pack
took another dexa skin just to see where
I was at and then adjust my trend lines
and I was able to relative relatively
accurately predict where I'm going to be
and when I'm going to get there and then
just weigh in every day you'll notice
that it goes up and down it's not a
linear process where it's just oh my
camera's reversed it's not a linear
process where it's just a straight 45
degree angle line down in terms of fat
loss some days you'll weigh in heavier
some days you'll weigh in way less I
always got the whoosh type effect which
was all you need is one of these just uh
yeah you know it's like a I mean it's
not focusing on obviously but it's one
of those tape measures that like uh
um yeah
that's how we got all these numbers over
here like you just you know just exactly
that you just take them yeah and measure
them and I've I've plugged them in
spreadsheets I've done trend lines and
tracked them and tried to predict where
I'm going to be I've done it enough
times now to where I know pretty much
how to do it without having to track it
as much as I did and also I don't do the
bulk and cut Cycles anymore uh so
usually for me I'm two to three weeks
out from a six pack at any given time uh
dude it's really about do you aim for
any symmetry because one of the things
that I learned is you know generally
speaking for you know for the Aesthetics
of symmetrical like like masculine
builds you generally want your arm
measurement like your buy and try
measurements to be the same as your calf
measurement
um my arms are like an inch bigger than
my calves and I'm a hard Gainer for my
legs like do you have any tips for
gaining muscle in like areas like do
your legs grow easily or are they hard
gainers uh I've got big legs I've never
had problems with legs I joke with guys
in the group but I train my legs like uh
these Instagram female fitness models
because they're just so big uh if I go
heavy heavy which I can't I'm actually a
strong guy when I when I train that way
but I just get so big I can't wear any
clothes I can't fit jeans I don't have a
fat waist but I have huge quads so that
makes it difficult so for me usually
again I'm more of an endomorphic body
type so for me usually it's restrict the
calories restrict everything and then
just try to be on the leaner side and
then when I'm super lean actually my
body's a near perfect proportion there
are some areas no one's gonna be perfect
perfect but Rich you always say it on
your channel you want to aim for that
golden ratio and for me it's really
about just getting rid of the fat a lot
of people think they can spot reduce you
can't it's it's all over your body if
you ever do a dexa skin they'll give you
presented body fat percentages per body
parts so when I'm overall like 10 or 11
body fat my arms are 6.7 or 7 body fat
so my arms are shredded my legs are
shredded my midsection I have of the the
six pack but it's but my midsection is
always a couple body percentage points
over the rest of my body so keep that in
mind too it's not it's all based on your
fat distribution that's that's a great
point because people think oh I'll do
them like you know my son is like I've
done so many crunches and done so many
sit-ups and you know I'm not getting a
six-pack so yeah you can't like reduce
fat in one area it's kind of like it's
like a tide it has to be reduced
everywhere
yeah that's exactly it then as you get
further into the diet so if you are
doing like a dedicated cut then you have
to start cutting stuff out so I did
intermittent fasting I usually do I'll
do a cheat day once a week and then
cheat day gets reduced to a cheat meal
and then cheat meals just go away so if
I wanna I'm two weeks out from Miami uh
cheat meals probably won't happen
between now and then because just those
extra calories and it's not all about
fat accumulation a lot of guys think
when they eat crappie that like oh I'm
putting on this body fat I call it slop
it's just that water retention and that
subcutaneous water and and just that
bloat and a lot of food when you eat
crappy food especially it's not it's not
necessarily putting fat on your frame
unless you're in a caloric Surplus it's
just the the tissue it just holds
everything for me I've always had like a
bloating problem too and I think that's
part of being an endomorphic body type
is you just want you your body just
wants to hold mouth
that's a good point because you know
when you get to my age I weigh myself
regularly on the digital scale and you
know if you have a few beers on a Friday
night yeah that can result that can
result in four pounds by Sunday you know
yeah I had a small bag of Cheetos last
night and like a little thing of cookies
and then this morning because I'm
getting I'm getting leaner I'm certainly
at the definition of my cheeks but this
morning just enough bloat to where you
can't see it anymore I'm like all right
damn it that's all it takes I did not go
over what I needed in a day calorically
but it's the type of food that I chose
to put in my diet and you can feel it
too because I've been eating pretty
clean these last few weeks like that
first cheat on crunch on it like your
body can feel it it's pure [__] it's
just not real food what about what about
the idea that the body fat scales are
useless I mean look they're not as
accurate in measurement to what you're
going to get with a dexa skin or I think
the most accurate is is where they do
that water displacement tank yeah right
that's that one but they're they're
consistently inconsistent assistant
right so I mean if I stand on my body
fat percentage scale that I've got
upstairs in my bathroom it basically
says that I'm 23 body fat I'm not 23
body fat but if I lose body fat it'll
show that I'm 22 or or 21.7 or something
like that if I gain then it shows that
I'm 24 or like whatever so they're like
you can use them as a consistent
inconsistent guide but if you want to
get an accurate measurement body fat
calipers decks of skin uh the water
displacement tanks are usually a you
know good way to go like ABS I you know
for me like I noticed that ABS usually
pop under about 12 13 body fat so if
you're not seeing ABS it's because
you're over that usually okay but pardon
me but uh naturally being the one who's
cooking bacon right at this moment what
the hell is a dexoscan
you want to explain it during yeah it's
like a 3D imaging thing you do so it's
kind of so much like a like a CT scan
where you go and kind of similar and
kind of not similar you go in you lay
down this platform and you have I
believe it's lasers and they come in the
and it takes a 3D image of your body and
it gives you a bunch of information in
terms of your body composition that's
between your muscle your bone uh your
your just body fat in general it gives
you a bunch of Dimensions so the
circumference of all of your different
limbs that gives you your fat
distribution pattern gynoidal versus
Android gynoidal is guys who usually
hire an estrogen so like I was obese as
a kid I have a guy noodle fat
distribution pattern which means it was
mostly on my inner thighs my hips my
butt my flanks that's kind of like
females that's that's a it's a that's an
effect of having too high estrogen uh
Androgen fat distribution pattern that's
more in the gut so guys that have big
beer guts I've never had a gut before I
always had the flanks and just fat on my
legs so uh it'll tell you that and it
gives you a lot of cool in insight and
then where do you get one of those
uh most major cities in the US will do
it I'm looking for one here it looks
like you have to go to specialized
hospitals but um but here and I'll pop
some stuff in the chat too so I took the
dexa information I plug it in this
tracker and then you can with relative
with relatively High degree of accuracy
predict what your fat loss journey is
going to look like as long as you're
sticking on your diet but you report
your calories you weigh in every day
rich like you said you want to have
consistent measurements so it doesn't
really matter what you do just do it
consistently step on the screen jiren
the yeah okay yeah go for it and then
I'll show I'll share a dexa with you too
I've got them in a folder somewhere so
I'm looking for them speaking so this is
how you track it like this is your this
is a serious geek app session right here
bro yeah oh yeah no it's it's good from
my perspective of someone who like you
know never spent more than three days in
one week in the gym
yeah and then if you go to the Chart
it'll show you the trend line so usually
when you start getting lower that the
data is going to get off you'll start
going negative and obviously you're not
going to have a negative body fat but um
but it gives me about where I want to be
like eight
and you're and your weight here's about
212. what's your height
uh I'm 5 11.
okay so you went from 212 down to 184.
yeah one 184 I was I was I was ripped I
was completely jacked you're about the
same height as grego Gallagher
um I had dinner with him about a year
ago he's he's in really good shape that
dude like he's like he's ripped like if
you look at his uh Instagram post I
think he's he normally carries himself
around 184. what do you weigh right now
oh I haven't weighed myself in a while
but I'd say I'm probably just shy of
200. normally am I walking around with
my my body likes to be between 195 205
if I go below one or if I go like 190
195 uh I start looking I start looking
actually bigger
um a little leaner but not super ripped
and then but when I go below 190 I look
like a fitness model yeah and then it's
that's what I always tell guys too like
once you have once you have your base
built then really it's just an effect of
body fat I know a lot of guys in the
group they're like oh I gotta keep
bulking got to keep getting bigger but
eventually you get pretty close to your
genetic Max and I've been in the gym for
20 years unless I up the trt does to
where it's no longer trt dose I'm not
going to get that much bigger I'm about
what my body likes to be yeah I really
hope you guys enjoyed that clip if you
want to watch the full length podcast
you can find that over here that clips
from if you're new to the channel make
sure you hit subscribe over here and pin
down below in the top comment you'll
find a bunch of useful links to my
website my supplement line books and a
bunch of other stuff have an amazing day
peace out